Heiko Maas ist Deutschlands neuer Außenminister.
Nachdem er am Mittwoch gemeinsam mit den übrigen
14 Ministerinnen und Ministern vereidigt wurde,
sprach er bei seiner Antrittsfeier im Auswärtigen
Amt.
Der 51-jährige SPD Politiker aus dem Saarland
sagte, er sei aus ganzem Herzen Europäer
und wolle sich als Minister auch weiter dafür
einsetzen Spaltungen innerhalb Europas zu
überwinden.
"Aber übrigens nicht nur aus Leidenschaft
für Europa, sondern auch aus Realismus"
Beim Thema internationale Staatengemeinschaft
warnte Maas vor Abschottung, er wolle Deutschlands
wachsender Verantwortung in der Welt gerecht
werden.
Seinem Vorgänger, Siegmar Gabriel, fiel der
Abschied dem Anschein nach nicht leicht.
"Ich glaube, dass Heiko Maas ein exzellenter
Außenminister ist und wird.
Lieber Heiko, ich wünsche dir dabei jeden
Erfolg.
Lieber Heiko liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen,
mir war es eine Ehre deutscher Außenminister
und damit auch Leiter dieses Hauses zu sein,
es hat Spaß gemacht hat.
Ich hoffe Ihnen auch.
Ich jedenfalls will es nicht verheimlichen,
dass es schön war.
Vielen Dank.
macht es gut und alles Gute.
Sie haben das Wort."
Schon während der Regierungsbildung hatte
Gabriel allerdings gesagt, mit Maas als Nachfolger
könne er sein Amt mit gutem Gefühl verlassen.
Er selbst war im Januar 2017 als Außenminister
angetreten.
Gleich im Anschluss an die Veranstaltung flog
Heiko Maas nach Paris, um den Schulterschluss
mit seinem Französischen Amtskollegen Le
Drian zu suchen.